our speaker who is this year has met us
um
i sort of joked i guess the last time i
did this i sort of joked that our last
graduate alum who actually got the
horace mann medal
um
actually won the nobel prize for
economics and the interesting part about
it is that he actually gave
his
uh forum speech in this room just before
brian so you know i think brian may be
following him in some ways i don't know
okay okay so dr keating uh trained as an
observational cosmologist at brown and
completed his doctoral degree here in
2000
he worked to design and build the first
generation technology and detectors to
measure a fundamental pattern of light
that would reveal a signal
from the big bang known as b-mode
polarization
dr keating is currently the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at uc
san diego center for astrophysics and
space science
he is also the principal investigator
and director of the simon's laboratory
project office which is under
construction
in the atom
atacama desert in northern chile
this observatory
will provide scientists a unique
opportunity to study the nature of
fundamental physical processes that have
governed the origin and evolution of the
universe
over 270 scientists engineer
technologists from over 35 institutions
around the world are contributing to
this project
dr keating has been recognized
throughout his early career
in 2005 to receive the national science
foundation faculty early career award
development award
followed by a presidential early career
award for scientists and engineers in
2007
and in 2016 he was appointed as a fellow
of the american physical society
additionally dr keating was elected as a
lifetime honorary member of the national
society of black physicists and
recognition of his ongoing support and
mentoring of students and junior faculty
from underrepresented groups
he is also a published author dr
keating's first book losing the nobel
prize was selected as one of best
science books of the year
at science friday amazon science news
physics today for forbes
in symmetry
magazine
his second book into the impossible
think like a nobel prize winner is
described as a mesmerizing collection of
interviews with some of the world's
brightest minds i'm not on that list
beyond this work dr keating has given
presentations to thousands of k-12
students
he is a board member with math for
america and the san diego air and space
museum and holds a trustee appointment
for the national museum of mathematics
he is currently the host of a podcast
streaming series called into the
impossible which has its own youtube
channel and is one of apples and
spotify's top 10 ranked science podcast
today today's topic is think like
galileo galileo galilei
how to remain relevant for half a
millennium please join me in welcoming
dr keith
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you dean campbell
thank you associate dean lewis and my
good friends
dr gang zhao my former professor
dr jim gates who inspires and mentors me
in many different ways gives me life
advice from the evoncular perspective
that only he can provide
and uh thank you to professor stefan
alexander my oldest friend my best man
at my wedding and uh you're gonna hear a
lot about stefan today we're going to
talk a little bit about how
the early connections that i made here
have endured and how it led me to the
precipice
of winning the nobel prize but losing it
ultimately spoiler alert it's called
losing the nobel prize and unfortunately
because i'm winning the hardest man
medal now i cannot write the book losing
the horace mann medal so
that's unfortunate but uh but it's all
worth it and so i'm so glad to see so
many people here today's talk will be
only feature 75 equations and it will
only require relativistic time dilation
to solve so i'm going to go back in time
today
and i'm going to take us back to when i
came here and today we're going to focus
on the power of mottos galileo galilei
is my mentor that speaks to me in a
conversation i like to think we're
having across the millennia and with
galileo's support and his advice i've
been able to overcome some some strong
obstacles and i think the relevancy of
an individual who can who can last
for half a millennia and probably for
many millennia to come
should inspire everybody even if you're
not a scientist and i hope that this
lesson will be communicated through some
of the lessons that i learned here at
brown starting in 1993. so i came here
in 1993 i got my phd after uh being away
and you'll find out that i actually
never wore the cap and gown that's
somewhere over there
and it's a good thing i didn't wear it
maybe back then because i don't think i
could fit into it you know it's pretty
pretty hard to not fit into a graduation
gown but given uh as as much as our
bodies change over the decades i
probably wouldn't fit into it so i never
did go to my graduation ceremony from
here so i am looking forward to it and
it's kind of one of my regrets and i
want to talk about the power of regret
the positive power of regret
but it all started here this is 1993.
first day of class
i met a young man
and he was from new york like i was
except he was from the real new york
real city new york bronx new york he had
a bronx accent i traded in my long
island accent for uh i don't know what i
had at that point but uh but maybe a
cleveland accent coming from case
western we met in the dungeon
the dungeon which still exists barris
and holly room 122. any physics students
here remember that besides me and stefan
and professor zhao um and there i also
met my uh my future boss
peter timby who's now professor at the
university of wisconsin-madison
and peter's been a lifelong friend of
mine as well the connections i've made
more connections here you know people
say in high school it's the best time of
your life then college is the best time
of your life
for me i found here was the best time in
my life the connections i made here
endure to this day i can scarcely say
that about other connections that go
back even farther but i've known stefan
you know twice i joke with my wife she
should be jealous because i've spent
more time with stefan over the years i
once tried to kill him you'll find out
about that in just a second also here at
brown
and really i became a scientist here i
became an intellectual i began to
hopefully follow in the great footsteps
of some of the faculty that taught me
and also to really be inspired by the
tradition of scholarship that this
mentor galileo had laid down for us as a
sort of a challenge to the generations
and i want to explain to you that his
his flaws make him even more endearing
to me and the failures that he had and
he had many lacunae and many setbacks in
his life as we'll talk about but he had
a
set of principles that he lived by and i
want to maybe see if they resonate with
you today
so friends that you make 30 years ago
almost to the year 29 years ago
can endure
and that's kind of the first lesson you
make a network in life and i've lately
become more i don't know if this is true
for for younger people in in my early
life when i would see something that's
really sad it would make me emotional
but now i get more emotional like happy
things and seeing things and and kind of
that's what inspires me but to think
this guy that i met i would be there
when he got and he would give me
the first ever printed copy he only had
two of these he gave me the first ever
printed copy of his first book
which is uh which is called the jazz of
physics everybody should get a copy
and then he would later endorse my first
book and continue to be
a mentor as he has risen through the
ranks and a colleague it's wonderful to
have colleagues that are mentors too
that was one of galileo's great
strengths he it was competitive ultra
competitive and you'll see some of the
things that he would do to trumpet and
kind of the puffery that he engaged in
later stefan would speak at the tedx
symposium at in san diego and i was
honored to be there and then uh earlier
before that as i said i almost tried to
kill him in this very plane
this is november 5208 quebec
stationed at the mighty lincoln north
central state airport has anyone ever
been to lincoln besides us this morning
okay it's a pretty rare place there is a
huge airport there that can land like
bombers and stuff i took steph on in a
ricketed ink plane flew him over
providence asked him to look over the
calculations of my thesis and if he
didn't the parachute was unfo
non-functional but uh we've remained
ideal friends even despite things you do
you almost kill somebody and they still
love you and remain
at your side through the ups and downs
and he's really been with me uh forever
i can not really repay him so who are
you guys you heard a little bit about me
from that speech that the dean read
written by my mother
and uh hopefully not to be rebutted by
my mother-in-law but the
brown graduation as i said i never i
never walked i never walked the only
graduation i ever attended was my
college graduation high school
graduation the only time i wore one of
these ridiculous pieces of regalia
that's completely non-functional thank
you susan for arranging to get me an
outfit for tomorrow my one of my sons is
here and he asked me if i can keep it
i'm like what am i going to use it for
um i guess i could become a judge or
something in the supreme court
and i want to hearken to what i first
saw back in 1993 i got a crisp linen
envelope
the most beautiful envelope i've ever
seen embossed with this beautiful color
red not crimson but red
and underneath it were written these
latin words which in 1992 and 1993
google didn't exist okay that would take
several years more
and it said in deo sparamus how many of
you know what endosporamis means
it means in god we hope
and i started thinking this is an
amazing place
that they look up to a heavenly being
even if you don't believe that's not
important to me but they look to the
heavens for inspiration another thing
that galileo often did we'll explore
that
but also the power of hope
there's hope hill mount hope hope street
and in god we hope what is hope hope is
an expectation
hope is sort of a plan of where you
might get to and where you might go and
when i saw that i felt like brown saw
that i had that saw something that was
hopeful about me
and that maybe i could go on to be
follow in the footsteps of some of the
great faculty and students that have
come from here
so i want to ask you do you have a creed
do you have a motto
galileo had a family crest
it was a ladder
a ladder with its base on the ground
with its top kind of tapering off
towards the heavens
and he didn't have one motto he had
three we're gonna go over his three
mottos of what would later become famous
to me and resonate with me throughout
the millennia as i said he was born in
the 1560s
amazing that it's almost 500 years since
he was born died in 1642 at archety
italy where i've spent many a time even
with stefan as well he had three
children no spouse which made it very
difficult for those children at that
time to go through life uh without any a
bonded uh
maternal and parental unit so they were
kind of ostracized his two younger
daughters especially the famous maria
celeste she was a nun in a convent and
they were considered illegitimate
and galileo had to support him
his son and his daughters as well as
many many jilted ex-lovers
and speaking of fatherhood he didn't
invent the telescope but he did perfect
it he was the first person to use an
instrument to compete and conduct the
scientific method and he for that reason
is called the father of modern science
by none other than the famous albert
einstein and we'll get into another one
beautiful collection and connection
between einstein and galileo in just a
bit
his first law
is a very famous one
he said it in the induction that he had
into the equivalent of the nobel prize
ceremonies back in the 15 and 1600s that
was called the academy of the lynx or
the linsayen society
and he was very proud of that that was
kind of like the horus man medal back
then uh and he
uh and he wore that title with with
great pride and he made use the lynx has
these huge eyes animal with enormous
eyes to observe and then to observe the
things that you can measure
and make measurable what is not already
so he used the telescope as sort of a
lever
and with this lever he displaced
figuratively the earth from the position
of centrality in the universe that had
enjoyed for millennia so to do that
required an incredible forceful
intellect he also came up with the
theory of relativity and that's one of
the connections with einstein it's
called galilean relativity and it shows
that your motion
whether physically on earth or
you know throughout your career is
determined by no absolute forces it's
determined and relative to the
perspective of an observer there is no
one omniscient omnipotent observer from
the perspective of physics at least
now
some of you here are going to become
academics some of you might follow in
the footsteps of jim gates stephon
alexander gang zhao andrew campbell you
may become a faculty member
and so to do that you've heard the
aphorism publish or perish
well galileo published a lot and he was
not only a great and wonderful
orator speaker writer he was also an
artist
and that made him unique he synthesized
both sides of his brain into one i can
never remember which side controls your
artistic side i don't know that probably
makes me one of the anyway the middle
diagram there shows not what the moon
actually looks like
nor what the moon looked like even to
galileo remember he was the first human
being in the history of our planet to
glimpse another world through a
telescope revealing details that would
transform our understanding of our place
in the universe
and yet he was brilliant in that he
could
even he could visualize for you the
viewer the visceral feeling of what it
felt like for him there is no crater
that looks like this one over there
there is no crit but he when he looks
through when he looked through the
telescope that's how it appeared to him
he he demonstrated through the
observations of other moons he
quintupled the number of moons that we
had went from one moon to five moons in
our solar system he recognized that when
he looked at the planet jupiter which he
depicts here this is in one of his most
artistic create even i could reproduce
this kind of thing the circle shows the
planet jupiter on one night this is in
1610.
uh the next night there are two stars
and i would have stopped there i would
have said okay the planet's moving they
knew the planets moved in fact the word
planet in greek means mover or wanderer
but then he came back the next night and
the next night and he does this for days
and months and it becomes kind of
tedious looking at his sketches in the
siderious nuncius which is written in
latin that's important remember that
fact
latin for the starry messenger he was
communicating things from the heavens
and so he depicted it what he realized
through the power of his brain and
through the visual depiction
this is the epitome of a renaissance
individual arts and science blended
together he realized he was looking at a
miniature solar system edge on
it was the only way to explain the
periodic behavior that he eventually
would propose as the first precise clock
in history
we take for granted the measurement of
time there's a clock back there
telling me i need to finish in the next
95 minutes which i promise i will
and yet he was able to depict these
things with such regularity that he
realized for the first time in history
it could be used as a precise time
keeping device anywhere on earth almost
any time of the year
and in so doing set the standard for
time keeping
which he had fascinated him as a young
man probably listening to a sermon by a
priest or something
that
you know he got so bored in church that
he apparently was watching the pendulous
oscillations of a chandelier overhead
and then he realized he could time the
this is at age six that he could time
the oscillations period using his pulse
unless he fell asleep and then he would
wake up and start timing again he
realized that the period was independent
of the amplitude one of the first laws
of precision motion 100 years before
newton would codify those laws amazing
individual
so he published a lot
he published one book in 1600 called the
compass which is really about a slide
rule can you imagine a book which is
worth several million dollars today
about a slide rule and back then it was
all the rage this is just a sampling of
his books he published and then the
question is of course did he perish
we all know something happened to
galileo what happened
after he invoked and overthrew
the ptolemaic the aristotelian if you
will the biblical view
that the earth was the center of the
entire universe the so-called geocentric
cosmos he overthrew it and said the sun
is the center of the universe
and that was done
with the aid of his mind and the spy
glass or what he called the perpiculum
the perspective tube because looking
through a telescope
is a time machine it shows you the way
things looked in the past and i'm
looking back naturally it's only natural
that you look back when you give a
speech like this
to where you were and see if your life
even makes sense
and as cern kierkegaard said life must
be lived forward but you can only
understand it looking backwards and the
telescope is this powerful tool that
does that
it literally moved from the human mind
at least where the earth was centered so
did he publish
well the pope generously allowed him to
study copernicanism
he published the cedirius nuncius the
latin for starry messenger he published
that in 1610 march 13 1610
and we published that
that book
that book was a scholarly work it wasn't
considered a popularization like the
jazz of physics fear of a black universe
losing the nobel prize in other books
it was considered a work of pure
scholastic interest that people didn't
speak latin on a daily basis
the dialogue on the other hand he was
forbidden to write in italian which was
the common parlance of the day the
dialogue means the dialogue
the conversation it's actually a trial
log between three characters
and i've had the honor along with my
good friend professor jim gates uh to
narrate the first time in human history
a book by galileo turned into an
audiobook just this year
no one had ever done it before and i
thought wow you know i only like to
listen to things i listen to my own
podcast
i only listen to audiobooks now
but it didn't exist when i wanted to
research my hero galileo so i said let's
see if we can do it with the help of
carlo revelli over noun science
popularizer frank wilcek nobel prize
winner up the street at this technical
college called mit
uh he narrated the introduction by
albert einstein and professor gates
narrated the translator stillman drake
and for me i narrated the part of the
intelligent lay person his name is grado
just means like some normal person then
there's two other characters there's
salviati which means the savior or
salvation in italian and salviati
is espousing the views of the genius
galileo
and then there's a character that
espouses the views of the pope and the
catholic church and galileo gave him the
unfortunate name simplicio
which means the simpleton
not so smart but it shows you great men
great minds great women can have great
flaws great blind spots even when they
use their telescopes
so he wrote this book and you see in the
top he's putting his he's putting his
version of the uh horace man or nobel
prize it says he's a member of the lin
saying society on the cover of the book
he was very proud of it and we should
take pride in our accomplishments and
the things that we do we look back
and i am so grateful for to have good
friends like this at brown and around
the world
so galileo had another motto when he was
first confronted by the pope that he had
perhaps violated an injunction against
teaching remember he was allowed to
research it but he couldn't teach it
nowadays as academics we cannot fathom
that what do you mean you're not going
to let me talk about my research in fact
i joke with my guests on my podcast that
scientists and other people we have a
moral obligation
to share what we do with the public not
just you know it's good if you can do it
no no no you have to do it because you
and the public pay my salary i'm at a
public institution i'm a product of
public schools as horus man commenced
for this great country and our country
is primarily great because of our
wonderful public school system and of
course it can be better and it will be
better but i'm a product of i teach in a
public university
and so the message of god of galileo and
of course man resonates with me
but galileo getting back to his uh his
story kind of in the middle of the three
acts his second motto
he said to the pope i don't think you're
reading this right the bible and science
are two different things the bible shows
us the way to the heavens and science
shows us how the heavens go
in other words they're what steven j
gould used to call non-overlapping
magisteria they don't really have that
much in common and it's true i once
looked up how many verses are there in
the old testament called the torah in
hebrew how many verses about the big
bang are there really there's about 35
verses about creation
and then there's 35 000 more verses
you're about 0.1 of this entire book so
galileo's right the bible isn't a
science book
any more than a jazz of physics or a
brief history of time is a book about
ethics morals and how to live your life
so i think it is important to take heed
to what galileo said
and then he kind of sticks it to the
pope and he says i do not believe that
the same god deo who endowed us with
sense and reason intended us to forego
their use so he's really saying no the
pathway if i can interpret the great you
know permission indulgence from the dead
this brave looking man right here keep
that image in mind
if i can indulge
he's really saying
if you want to access the mind of god or
the highest power call it mother nature
then science is perhaps your best vector
to do that the best vehicle to
understand the sublime is to use science
in my humble opinion and i should say
that galileo made many blunders not just
political blunders
he also had what we call now
confirmation bias
which is the tendency that scientists
and normal people have
to accept evidence only when it conforms
to their hypothesis
and to reject or file away
evidence that might be contradictory
disconformational
and we have to grapple with that every
day as a scientist and i often said the
only thing i didn't learn here and it
doesn't mean that i didn't learn like to
be an ethical person from great teachers
like the late great jerry geralnick and
people that became like uncles or father
figures
i learned that you should be ethical but
we don't teach ethics the way medical
students do we don't teach them the way
law students do
and i think scientists can be held to
these high standards of of ethical
imperatives uh so that's just my a
little hobby horse along with the moral
obligation to scientists to
give back to the public who pay their
salary the learning and the education
that we are getting on their
generous funding roles
so galileo thought the tides on the
earth were caused purely by the rotation
of the earth and the revolution of the
earth around the sun
sort of a sloshing like in this
bottle of water as you spin around it
kind of sloshes back and forth
in reality has nothing to do with that
but he put that in the dialogue because
he wanted to prove this idea that the
earth is in motion around the sun and
not the other way around
so in doing so he actually made the
biggest blunder of his life because it
has nothing to do with that diurnal and
um annual emotion whatsoever it's caused
by the moon the very beautiful object he
sketched through the perspective tube on
those nights in early 1610.
and so now you see a less kind of proud
brave looking galileo he's in front of
the holy office
which is a euphemism
as i like to say in the same way that
the internal revenue service is a
euphemism for like the money donation
service or or what have you so here he's
looking you know kind of a little bit
he's cowering there's a guy with a big
stick there uh and there's his there's
the pope pope urban who had been his to
his student and had wanted to learn
about science
but galileo thought his brilliance could
evade the injunction against teaching
and nowadays we should take advantage we
don't have such injunctions we're free
to do anything in this country and from
this great university
launched to do anything and we should
and we should share and we should go
where the science takes us and beware
all the time of these biases that we
have now there's a popular myth that he
was tortured he was thrown in prison he
actually got to live less than a
kilometer from his beloved daughter
maria celeste
at the convent where she was in our
chetri stefan's been here this is a
lovely place i mean i think bernie
madoff would have been really you know
keen to be spending a time in this kind
of a prison quote unquote you can see
the duomo not far away there's this
beautiful quadrangle he could go see his
daughter his daughter would come see him
and he had grape vines and olive trees
and he wrote some beautiful poetry and
he wrote another book here
under house arrest
so can you imagine such a thing
happening if he was truly tortured and
imprisoned he wrote his final book with
with the help of jim and with god uh
perhaps we can translate again the
discoursey the dialogue on two new
sciences where he really lays out the
scientific method for the first time in
human history he couldn't publish that
in italy so smuggled out published by
elsevier the same press that we all know
and love today in the netherlands in
leiden in uh uh 1638 so six years after
the dialogue and then he died two years
four years later
but um getting back to brown in those
famous times when i almost killed stefan
so brown used to own
an airplane
and when you hear an ivy league school
owns an airplane you know then the
dean's ears get you know really excited
dean lois dean campbell right maybe we
can get a gulf stream for brown let's
ship it no no this is brown's
university's plane uh so even the ivy
league has to you know has to have
modest means this is a two-seat plane
uh tail number november 5208 quebec i
got my pilot's license in my second year
of graduate school
and on the very first day of after i got
my license i went out took stephon as i
said
almost killed him but he came back safe
and sound
and this is where i learned some lessons
about perseverance it's cliche to talk
about grit resilience perseverance and
kind of a commencement form like this
but but it's true i learned especially
about the power
of wind
and the power of wind
should not be over or underestimated
and what i learned from my instructor
there stefan and i fly off into the
sunset
has to do with a little math lesson i
said there's 75 equations there's only
two equations in this whole talk hope
you'll indulge me
first one goes like this
california where i am between san diego
and san francisco where we're going to
go next
is about 500 miles
if you fly there
from san diego to stanford where we're
going to go next as i say
it's about a one hour flight if you go
on a commercial southwest jet
the jet goes 500 miles an hour and let's
say you have a tailwind pushing you
along
smooth flights tailwinds all the way so
you're going 600 miles an hour it will
take less than an hour if it's 500 miles
away
now
you come home that night going back to
san diego what happens to you well now
you're battling a headwind pushing you
at 100 miles an hour reducing your speed
so i'm going to ask you show of hands
the only equations you have to solve i
will solve for you so let's say you come
back into town how long does the round
trip take
does it take more than an hour raise
your hand if you think it takes more
than two hours round trip
okay
raise your hand if you think it takes
less than two hours round trip remember
you have a tailwind going there headwind
coming back
and now raise your hand if you didn't
raise your hand
raise your hand if you're terrified of
raising your hand in public
okay so let's do the math how long does
the thousand mile long round trip take
in a plane that can go 500 miles an hour
when there's no wind
takes longer
you could never benefit and you can just
see this for yourself what if the
tailwind was 500 miles an hour you get
there in a half an hour how long would
it take to get back
infinite all right very good good
student in the front
it would net you'd never get there do
you spend more time
fighting against headwinds than you do
breezing along in the tailwinds i
learned that from my instructor greg
vandenker when i was here in 1995 uh
it's just amazing so i actually as i
said i got my master's degree didn't
walk in that commencement
commencement ceremony didn't walk in my
phd ceremony in 2000
so i'm really delighted to be walking
tomorrow whatever i'm going to do
tomorrow wearing a silly uniform
i think we all should do that as much as
we can
and i went off to stanford university
and stefan can vouch for me this is my
dream place to be
stanford
beautiful campus
lovely students that go there
and i wanted to be a part of the
stanford community
and it was home to many nobel prize
winners and i was going to work for a
young assistant professor by the name of
sarah sarah church
and i was always kind of living in that
moment when am i going to get my phd
when am i going to get my phd and how
many of us phd students former ones can
kind of vouch for that the campus is
really
you know there's a reason they call it
the brown of the west coast right i mean
it's one of the most beautiful campuses
in the entire country
looks like this it has multiple logos
multiple mottos but we're going to focus
on this motto here
so we just talked about the power of
headwinds
this one says
de lofte freijbret
can i ask uh
where's uh any stanford graduates here i
know there's one here any other ones do
you know what the motto means sir
the wind of freedom blows
so it's not latin it's not in english
it's in german which will be important
later on
it's almost as old as brown not quite
try harder next time brown uh stanford i
mean so it means the winds of freedom
blow and guess what happened i blew over
to stanford and i immediately got
obsessed with an idea that galileo had
inspired me about when i was a 12 year
old kid
which was to build a type of telescope i
didn't know how when i was 12 but i sure
as hell knew how to do it once i left
this august institution i was a trained
scientist by the way the word scientist
in russian
means someone who was taught
so it doesn't mean like technical stuff
it means a person who was taught so
we're all scientists here anyone who's
curious anyone who seeks as imagination
can be a scientist so we're all
scientists
and i knew after the training i received
here
that i could perhaps go back to the very
beginning of time which is the epoch of
inflation so-called cosmological
inflation when the universe expanded not
the monetary inflation that you hear
about the universe expanded by 30 orders
of magnitude in a time period less than
a trillionth of a trillionth of a second
an event more violent than any other
event in cosmic history and it would
leave shrapnel in the form of waves of
gravity percolating through the universe
that could be detected by instruments
that we could build
so the cartoon diagram
that is from the washington post from
bicep when bicep made a huge
announcement in 2014 they depicted it
pretty well in schematic form inflation
is the spark that ignited the big bang
we are the byproducts every
every helium atom in the universe that
we know about with the exception of
those produced in stars and every
hydrogen atom in the water that you
drink and the water that's in your body
was produced during the big bang but how
did the big bang
get hot what put the bang in the big
bang
that is inflation
and so i wanted to detect inflation i
want to detect the analog of these
signals harbinger imprimatur signals
from the origin of the universe
the biggest unsolved problem in
cosmology
so while i was at stanford working on
professor sarah church's other projects
i spent most of my time dreaming about
other projects projects that i would do
and i was a terrible
employee
i was not a good postdoc so post docs
here at brown please do not follow my
lead
although as you'll see it worked out
well
i ended up designing mentally and
embodying when i became a postdoc at
caltech
this obsession which we call bicep the
background imager of cosmic
extragalactic polarization which is a
refracting galilean telescope
i'm convinced if galileo could be
teleported to now wherever he is or soul
is or if you believe in such things he
would instantly recognize hey that you
stole my idea
because this telescope is a refracting
lens-based telescope except unlike
galileo's telescope it uses transition
edge superconducting detectors cooled
down to 0.3 kelvin properties of which i
learned about in professor zhao's class
many many decades ago
and it has features that galileo would
instantaneously recognize and realize
is uniquely capable to go after the
signals that we're seeking
unfortunately then i got fired okay i
like to joke that i was fired just as
galileo was imprisoned by the catholic
church i was fired by the sarah church
at stanford uh but um but we're we're
still on good speaking terms and
actually she did me the biggest favor of
my life because she got me another
postdoc with her former postdoctoral
advisor uh the late andrew lang at
caltech
now i realized that stanford and
speaking about getting fired is not too
bad a thing for a commencement type
speaking engagement you all have
probably seen this is never going to
give any kind of address i've given high
school commencements first thing i do is
go back to steve jobs famous 2005
commencement address at stanford where
he talks about getting fired was the
best thing that ever happened to me
and
the only thing i have in common with
steve jobs perhaps is that that
statement's true for me too
if i didn't get fired i probably
wouldn't be here today
because what we did
is eventually
we moved to another
uh institution that has i moved to
university of california san diego
whose motto is let there be light spoken
by
another g god og the original god
and uh and that's usually we say it in
english because nobody understands fiat
lux
uh and it's one of the most exquisite
places to be and i'm just incredibly
blessed to work with these people who
help me design build deploy
field analyze and publish
can't forget to publish
data from the most sensitive instruments
ever built by my
a wonderful team around the world and in
particular my uc san diego crew
now we couldn't do this measurement from
providence we can't do it from
california we had to take it to the
coldest driest highest continent on
earth which is the south pole antarctica
which galileo didn't even know existed
if you think about it they didn't know
that the south pole existed until 1912
and people suspected it did 1911 when it
was first reached
it was quite a trip to get there and you
see the two teams that were battling
every bit as much in competition as they
battled to land on the moon for the
first time must have been
this is the moon race of the early 1900s
two teams
different technological approaches be
like one team you know wants to have uh
wings and fly into space the other one
has a rocket which team do you think
made it there first
the team that used uh these types of
animals to pull their sled or the team
that used these types of animals to pull
the slip i'll give you a hint uh the
station is named the amundsen scott
south pole station because amundsen got
there first the others died they died in
march
1912. uh just three weeks after missing
being the first to the south pole they
all froze to death because they didn't
plan properly and remember the hope is a
plan endosporamis you can't only hope
hope is not a strategy it's an element
and a component it's a motto
it's a creed those are important without
hope nothing could get done
but they failed to plan and when you
plan to fail you fail to plan
so they died unfortunately
uh just a few weeks later scott saw the
norwegian flag from a distance he
realized he had lost this moon race of
the 1900s be like neil armstrong
stepping out of the eagle and standing
on a soviet flag
it must have been the most disappointing
thing that ever happened
in the history of humanity and then to
know they're probably gonna die because
they got there so late
so nowadays it's uh it's a beautiful
place your tax dollars again are at work
here they built this station this
hundred million dollar station where i
would go for free and in fact people
tourists paid to go there so you guys
paid for me to go down there for free
multiple times with my students to get
training to build the most sensitive
instruments ever built
of course you have to take a selfie put
on instagram to get there
and i said it was dangerous when scott
and amundsen were there i failed to
mention how dangerous it still is today
this video it's grainy but you'll see
it's also quite dangerous today the
natives
um but maybe they don't like you know
it's kind of like faculty they don't
like each other right sometimes right
professors um so maybe they they would
be fine with people and one of my kids
is here he loves penguins he asked me
you know can you bring me back a penguin
so i tried i honestly tried to get a
penguin for my beloved son
and that's what happened so you got to
be very very cautious with these uh they
look gentle but they're they're not
so remember i said we're trying to
detect this pattern of gravitational
waves which would be the impromature of
the inflationary epoch that would
signify how the universe came to be
and perhaps be a harbinger of other
universes in a paradigm subsumed within
the inflationary
hypothesis called the multiverse
hypothesis which is a whole other talk
so we made this announcement and there
was a media storm
in fact one of the founding fathers of
inflation was by then he had emigrated
from the soviet union to stanford
university so stanford keeps appearing
in this talk
on the day of this announcement which
was held at the center for astrophysics
at harvard
stanford had prepared a video weeks
earlier showing this professor linday
receiving congratulations from one of my
colleagues professor challen quo at
stanford university and he weeps on
camera it's amazing it's very touching
video three million views the first
hours that it's out unbelievable
that same day in march of 2014 we were
on the washington post we were on tv
here's uh live from cnn i like this
remember i love mottos i collect mottos
i collect creeds does anyone know whose
motto this is reaching for the stars you
guys are all too young to remember casey
kasem keep your feet on the ground keep
reaching for the stars anyone remember
that jimmy remember that no
okay so they even bring in the motto
it was on the front page of the
newspaper of record
the san diego union tribune
there's me staring wistfully up at the
heavens there it is in the new york
times scientists detect space ripples
signifying the big bang's smoking gun
really the first physical evidence of
the origin of the universe what could be
more exciting
i like this headline
politically incorrect headline in the
economist it says like some guy
he just saw the big bang how amazing
that's amazing phenomenal so we got a
tremendous amount of attention but
we were actually this is a depiction
from a review of my book losing the
nobel prize in nature because we had
been told
that we would win a nobel prize whoever
came up with this idea
maybe me
would be in a short list to win the
nobel prize so nature depicted it as all
these cosmologists are looking to the
heavens to see the sign of inflation the
multiverse the big bang surefire nobel
prize
and in fact
the day i got here and stefan got and i
got here in 1993 there was a nobel prize
to holston taylor and uh and hulse was a
graduate student working with joe taylor
when he won the nobel prize 1993 the day
that stefan and i were here nobel prize
a graduate student won the nobel prize
maybe it could happen to us we always
thought about that
but you know you've made it when you
appear in the most august most important
most prestigious journal in all of
science
the onion the onion is here so they did
a headline the top theoretical
physicists
r b singers
meet to discuss the meaning of forever
and down here you see we can observe
long-term phenomena like the cmb
primordial b-mode polarization and the
love between india ahri and her man
all of which seem to have existed since
the universe's infancy you got diana
ross you got michio kaku i think jim
gates is off to the right over here you
can't see him uh and smokey robinson uh
so you're in the meme culture now now we
made it into the meme verse
but always in the back of your mind
are you making the same mistake that
galileo made maybe he won't get tortured
and put in jail or whatever happened to
him
but maybe there's something else leading
to a sense of confirmation bias
precluding you from seeing the truth
maybe something as small as a grain of
dust can impede your view
of how the universe came to be and you
may mistake the dust
for the primordial signals that would
lead to golden treasures
so here's a famous cartoon by sydney
harris
it shows two housekeepers sure it's
beautiful but i can't stop thinking
about all that interstellar dust out
there now we had thought about
interstellar dust as an interloper
imposter signal that could mock the
impromature of inflation we had taken
that into account we couldn't get access
to the data those were held by italian
and european collaborators and they
wouldn't share with us because they
didn't have the data fully analyzed they
didn't want to be premature but we went
ahead with it we published it anyway and
just like all those things that were
printed on the front page of newspapers
we got barely a blurb in the saturday
edition of the new york times when the
retraction of these results came out
and so we actually retracted this that's
why my book is called losing the nobel
prize
not winning the nobel prize
and it's not a how-to guide i don't want
anyone to lose it you know prematurely
but it was signifying that we had made a
mistake and then we needed to do better
and with the help of our theoretical
analytical and other experimentalists we
are now building a new project because
we now know the cosmos isn't so pure and
pristine
it's not this pristine view from here on
earth looking all the way back to the
beginning of time no
it's a lot
like boston at rush hour it's smoggy
it's smoky and there's a lot of schmutz
to look through and you have to be
attuned to it and remove it by paying as
much attention to it as you did to the
prize you're seeking to find
so to that end we built the site we are
building the simon's observatory and i'm
here to report progress on this
observatory and it will begin taking
data in just two years from now this is
a hundred million dollar plus project
and i'm pleased to co-lead with my
collaborator suzanne staggs who's a
spokesperson
at princeton and i'm the director of our
project office and we have over 200
researchers on all seven continents
and uh in multiple different countries
i'm almost adding names to this
wonderful list as uh as each passing
talk goes by this is our location in the
atacama desert it's called the desert of
deserts at the uh in the highest atacama
uh chilean andes range
and this is a beautiful shot of it 17
200 feet above sea level
it's funded by members all those members
you saw pay membership dues
and contribute in cash or in kind to
this immense observatory so that we have
as jim simons often says skin in the
game we need to have a steak a venture
in this in this project
here's a team we're gonna have a
face-to-face meeting for the first time
in three years uc san diego here's my
particular team at uc san diego working
on one of the three refracting galilean
type telescopes that will hopefully see
not only the signals of cosmic inflation
but also the dust simultaneously
and went to that end we built we're
building three of these instruments and
then we're deploying them to chile
which is at 17 000 feet above sea level
this is a video taken last month
hopefully the video works yeah it's a
time lapse video so it looks kind of
funny i like these instruments as the
class telescope
they're kind of wearing around we're
delivering those platforms that will
hold the three telescopes i'll speed it
up because it's kind of long
so we have these cranes we have to do
everything we have to build the site
bring the concrete bring the diesel fuel
to run the generators bring the oxygen
that we have to breathe or else we'll
pass out and die
and we have to maintain a culture of
safety and respect and respect the
indigenous people that populate this
land to this very day
and so it's just an immense privilege to
be affiliated with these uh with these
people and it's going to be building the
most sensitive experiment ever made not
only to measure the cmb signals but to
measure the dust signals as well
so i want to finish now with a statement
that even galileo's broad peripatetic
intellect was so expansive he even
thought about that classic question
if a tree falls in the forest
and nobody hears it does it make a sound
according to my friend philip gough at
durham
he was the first person to ever think
about the role of consciousness in the
physical world and in physical
perception and even to the extent of
considering such questions that we all
ask ourselves as kids
and so let's go back to that tree and
that motto that we just heard from a
graduate dialoft the free height lit
the winds of freedom blow
so i was blown free of a paycheck
from stanford university
but um but when you think about these
trees like that logo that stanford has
it makes me think about how the tiniest
of seeds that grow into enormous
sequoia trees the tree
this immense
largest biological organism on the
planet they start from the very smallest
of seeds
and that's the way something can happen
in life
the word providence where we are is
another form of serendipity it means
serendipity divine serendipity if you
will
and and everything that i have started
because of what i learned here and
coming from here
and in fact 11 years ago i brought a guy
he was just a little sprout now he's in
the audience and uh and he wouldn't be
here because i wouldn't have gone from
where i did at brown to stanford to
caltech to ucsd wouldn't have met my
wife and had the blessings that i have
to call part of my family and to be part
of this grand scientific tradition so i
thought it was the worst thing that
happened to me like steve said
getting fired only time i ever get fired
as a postdoc after leaving brown how
dare they
but it happened
and it made me think of my mottos and i
think we have to have models so this is
my final motto
it's in yiddish
combination of hebrew
and german
and it stands for
man it says
means man plans and god laughs at your
plans
it's kind of you know the the
bittersweet uh humor of the yiddish
language uh but it made me think of all
the wonderful things and that we do need
to have in life mottos and creeds like
galileo
we do need to wear robes and regalia
this is precious we only have a very
short amount of time together on this
wonderful planet and to enjoy
to not enjoy the fruits that you get to
accumulate the people you get to meet
the networks you get to enjoy and
benefit from intellectually physically
spiritually emotionally
so remember that
providence does stand for this divine
sense of serendipity and from which for
me at least all beautiful things have
flowed
and i think it's very important that we
have this perspective as galileo called
the perspective tube
to look back gives you perspective to
allow you to lead and go forward in your
life
so i think the last thing i will say is
it all began for me
with that motto in deus paramas have
hope open higher power perhaps but for
me everything started with hope and with
that i thank you very much for hosting
me today it's such an honor to be back
here at brown
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am
uh so as the uh the horace mental metal
uh medalist uh dr keating will get the
horace mann medal at um commencement
uh tomorrow tomorrow yeah
so um
we'll get to see him receive that medal
in the meantime we have a a couple of
microphones in the aisle if there are
questions please come to the microphone
and ask your questions please
good day yes professor
well first of all uh brian i want to
thank you for
just a terribly engaging presentation
that uh
basically uh
lives up to horace mann
i've got two things for you you
mentioned uh and i'd like to get your
reaction you mentioned that teachers
need to be free to teach
and yet we live in a country nowadays
where certain histories
are not allowed to be taught so i'd like
to get your reaction to that
second question
uh horace mann said what i believe is
the ultimate in commencement comments
which was
be afraid to die
until you have rendered some
service to humanity
and i'd like to know
what is that service that you've
rendered so those are my two questions
simple question i usually preface that
with simple questions from jim gates
that's what that that qualifies the
symbol i'll start with the first one so
harshman was a towering intellect he
recognized that the foundation of
freedom is education
and he was a huge um he was one of the
early and most powerful voices of
abolition against slavery uh starting in
the 1850s and and beyond and recognizing
that it shouldn't we shouldn't just free
the slaves to make them uh you know
because it's a good thing to do he
recognized the biblical injunction he
was appealing to biblically literate
people that it was actually a sin it was
it was no less than a sin
to enslave another person but he added
and you know this jim he said it's not
enough just give them freedom ship them
on their way we had to educate and keep
them
basically he said he wouldn't be
satisfied until they had armies
basically armies of freed black slaves
that that was when they would know that
they had made it and that america had
lived up to the promise of the
declaration of independence and he
resonated very much with frederick
douglass in that in that effect
um so i agree uh entirely and we see
that oh it couldn't happen again we
couldn't have that
there's a place on earth where slavery
takes place to this day
and and it's a great tragedy and
the thing that i want to understand is
and i started to think about this and
answer maybe to your first question
about service for me
when i think about service i think about
something i also learned here which is
which is about networking but not like
social climbing it's about building
connections between people
so you guys all know this and many of
you know this the basis of a network is
that it scales as this not the number of
people in the network but the square of
the number of people
because all of your connections may have
connections amongst themselves
and what i try to do and embody in my
life is i ask well what if you like kind
of short circuit a connection what does
that do to the rest of the network
and so for me i asked the question well
what you should do in life is that which
if taken away from you
would devastate you in other words you
should have those connections that you
can't live without for some it's
children some people don't have children
some it's friendship
and that type of service in the mind and
recognizing i do what i do because i'm
free
one of my colleagues the late great
professor
hans parr at ucsd he said we're only
allowed to do what we do as theoretical
and experimental physicists because
there's no war and the country doesn't
need our resources devoted to a mass
project to kill other human beings
and so i think about that a lot how
blessed we are as intellectuals in this
room and outside of this room and that's
how we should serve
to do that to give back to the public so
that they experience the return on their
investment in our education because
everybody here is benefit i don't care
if you went to private school all the
way through brown which is private
school all the way to graduate school
teach at a private school i don't care
we all benefited from this investment
in our civilization and to the extent
that we squander that that will then be
a time to be disappointed in the promise
of america the check that free that
frederick douglass talked about not
being cash
before i worked at brown i worked at
university of chicago and we were
working toward fundraising for the giant
magellan telescope also in the atacama
desert i was wondering
are they next to each other i understand
that's a great place to do that kind of
work are they different types of
instruments what yeah yeah so i actually
had the honor to visit along with jim
and marilyn simons
we broke ground so i had the 20th
richest guy in the world and his
beautiful wife marilyn um we were up at
17 000 feet with shovels i had them
shoveling dirt and he's wearing oxygen
trying not to smoke a cigarette and
and then we went from there down to a
ceremony to watch the total solar
eclipse at the giant magellan telescope
which is under construction 26 meter
wide diameter telescope uh larger than
this room and it has the capability to
look back and see completely different
things than what we would see with the
simon's observatory or bicep it can see
the atmospheres of exoplanets it can see
the very first stars that form but it
cannot see these signatures of inflation
or gravitational lensing gravitational
radiation neutrinos etc so they're
complementary but i think they both
serve the two highest purposes actually
i think there's three highest things
that the people can study in one way or
another and interest me how the universe
come from a non-universe how did life
come from non-living chemical matter and
had a consciousness emerge from living
matter those are the three kind of big
bangs that i'm most interested in are
chicken and egg problems and so that
will we're hopefully invested in the
first of those three and the second of
those three is the purview of the giant
magellan telescope
but yes they do need money but i think
brown needs more money no i'm just
kidding
so i had a question uh one of the things
i would say i was worried about
behaviors of the police that are really
the enemies of creativity
i'm thinking about what you did how you
approach science going from brown to
stanford and going off and doing your
own thing i just think about your
relationship with your own students in
terms of how you mentor them and guide
them do you say don't do what i do do
what i say or you say
you know
how do you yeah so i always say that you
know scientists cliche scientists are
like children
they're curious they're inquisitive
they're imaginative
and i say yeah but they're also like
children what do you mean i said they're
like children yeah they're jealous
they're petty they don't play well with
friends they want their own toys they're
not going to share with their siblings
science is kind of like one of many
double-edged swords
it takes a certain amount of humility to
do science to know that you could be
wrong and have the courage to say the
most powerful words in science i don't
know
um but also you need to have some
swagger you need to be able to say i am
capable of revealing the mind of nature
of mother nature that a human mind can
comprehend as richard feynman said i'm
an atom in the universe and a universe
of atoms a molecule contemplating the
cosmos and so we are unique we don't
know of any other life forms in the
universe for sure besides us a lot of
people think there are i personally
don't think there are but that's for
another talk
but fun talk about exobiology but on the
other hand we know for sure that we
exist and yet as jim brought up you know
we also don't treat each other very well
even scientists don't treat each other
well and so i think to the community to
my students i have a big plaque made by
one of my graduate students darcy baron
who's now a professor at the university
of new mexico she has graduate students
i have like grand baby grad students if
you like i have a plaque that was made
by her parents in honor of me when she
graduated a beautiful bronze plaque and
it shows my phd genealogy and it goes
back 17 generations
to uh before galileo wrote that first
book the compass
and uh it's an awesome responsibility
because the chain doesn't end you know
it goes back well that way we just don't
know their names and it goes all the way
down into the future and that's the
notion of what this russian phrase
interpretation of scientists means
someone who was taught that means to me
you have an obligation to teach as a
scientist
but to give back is also meaning that
you also have to have a little bit of
humility but swagger as well and
balancing those two it's the hardest
thing to do
thank you that was great
outside of galileo can you name one
other person who's inspired you and why
ah so in science or when without signs
um i would say you know besides my
wife who is the most inspirational
person i've ever had in my life she
really
has
truly endowed me with a complete other
side of my brain again i don't know
which side it is um and maybe you know
as we were saying earlier any of the
faults are with me and any of the good
things come from her so besides her in
that sense as a scientist there are many
because science to me means that you
don't back away there's another famous
blunderer in science he had seven
blunders he thought that quantum
mechanics wasn't real he thought that
their universe didn't have dark energy
he thought that the uh there was
anomalies in the basic foundations of
physics and his name was albert einstein
he was wrong as many times as he was
right he could have won seven nobel
prizes and he could have won seven egg
nobel prizes um
that's greatness when he saw that the
universe had evidence
that the universe wasn't static as he
presupposed it was
he said i was wrong it was my biggest
blunder and to have that kind of
humility
also he had a tremendous amount of
hutzpah you know he had that hope and
that ability to to um have confidence in
himself balancing those two he is a
great exemplar of it there are other
people that i respect tremendously um
scientifically or outside of science as
well
but but i think you know in terms of
what can i actually learn and apply
people like those two are probably at
the top of my list as a scientist
so when you were at brown
um and we're not going to ask you to
pick favorites i know you have you
probably have about five or six but in
terms of
professors here when you were you know a
young and
who do you
because you know who exemplifies some of
those things to you
yeah yeah i know you have a few but yeah
no definitely a few i mean i can't
ignore my advisor peter timmy um uh you
know but but well while you know he and
i
um are still the best of friends so it's
it's hard and impossible for me not to
to thank him professor ballas you know
he was like one of the guys and you know
you could relate to him there were
people i couldn't relate to because they
were so brilliant people like michael
kosterlitz uh professor kosterlitz uh
professor cooper who is incredibly um
incredibly
debonair and and stylish
as a physicist uh but i think the one
that i most resonated with and i regret
that i didn't spend as much time with as
i could have was late jerry growling
jerry was a tremendous human being
individual i'm blessed to be in touch
with his son and his wife
and um
he taught me you know some of the
greatest lessons that i still think
about in fact one of my favorite ones
that i use almost on a daily basis i can
hear him saying it we'd go after class
jerry
vuncular
uh professor brilliant professor came up
with the idea for what would later be
called the higgs boson um he would i
would go and like open the door for him
to get out of class and say no i never
let a grad student walk behind me you
don't know what they're going to do
[Laughter]
so he was a mensch he was a real mensch
and and i i try to embody that along
with the the swagger and the flare and
from professor xiao this is true you
gave me some of my lowest grades in the
class that's okay but you you believed
in me and and you allowed me to
demonstrate when i didn't know something
that uh you gave me a second chance and
you allowed me to come back and show you
that okay that was just an off day you
had grace you had graciousness that
really did speak to me and i try to
think about that with my students today
during the pandemic these kids are
dealing with stuff they're all over the
world literally in a uh calling in all
hours of the night i'm not the greatest
teacher
but i try to have some graciousness and
understanding that these are individuals
and um and i think i learned a lot of
that from this very institution and of
course from you i i can't i already i
already spoke about you for like 10
minutes brother i mean come on
no it's true you did i dedicated my book
to you don't don't forget that
okay uh we have time for one more
question
how powerful was galileo's
telescope
in comparison with a modern telescope ah
very good question so galileo's little
tiny telescope was about an inch and a
half in diameter there's one lens out of
the hundreds of telescopes that he
probably made
he would never tell people how he made
it
because he had a monopoly on it would be
like steve jobs explaining how did the
iphone work you know so somebody can
copy it once you have monopoly you want
to keep using it so he wouldn't tell
people how he made it instead
he published the cedarus nuncius which
showed what you could see with it which
gave you anticipation desire you wanted
it and he published that it became
instantly famous across the whole
continent of europe he never left italy
this telescope you can see
these objects
and in fact you can see with a telescope
in the middle of providence on a clear
night
every single thing that galileo ever saw
nebulae
he saw the imp these planets uh that had
moons around them the phases of venus
are depicted in the bottom left corner
the
rings of saturn are depicted this is
something you can get if you buy
a keating brand 2000 telescope for only
19.95 99 no i really do want to go into
business and get uh make telescopes but
you can find amazon you could buy for 50
you could buy the exact same telescope
that inspired me as a 12 year old to go
into a life of what would later be
called science and kind of rediscover
these same discoveries and i always say
you can't go out and build a large
hadron collider you can't go out and
build a giant magellan telescope but you
can feel the exact feeling
that another human being had who's been
dead for 500 years because when you look
and you see saturn and you see the
craters on the moon you immediately say
these are not like
anything we've ever seen before without
a telescope so you'll feel what he felt
no other scientific instrument can do
that so i encourage parents get your
kids or grandkids telescopes please and
i promise to take your money someday
when i build my own telescope company
thank you very much okay why don't we
give dr king a big hand please
thank you